[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
happy week four everybody welcome to the
squad ride live in the bleacher report
app presented by draftkings brady is
returning to foxboro tonight we're gonna
talk a lot of pat's bucks today but by
now you know me you know greg who's got
something extra special to give away
today to the comment section we are
really happy to welcome in a hall of
famer anytime who's winning this game
tonight
man you know what as a betting man i'm
going to say
brady was going to win but when you're
talking about
where my heart want to go i'm definitely
going and i'm cheering on the patriots
you know what i mean but i think from a
team standpoint uh the the bucks have
the advantage you know what i mean but
hey it's time to it's time to get it
upset today you know what i mean
belichick might have something up his
sleeve i'm just a little bit concerned
personnel wise could they match up but
uh you never know get a special teams
get a turnover you know good things can
happen so uh i'm i'm going for
the patriots but if i was betting money
i'll bid on the bucks a smart man don't
bet with your heart that's right answer
absolutely all right we're doing things
a little bit different this week every
week we ask you for anytime touchdown
scores but it's a special week like we
said brady returning to foxboro we got
ty law here which is just awesome brady
is 68 yards away from breaking the
all-time passing record and we want to
know from you the squad who we think the
lock is to catch that record-breaking
pass on friday we asked you on social
and in the app to drop your picks these
are the most popular picks you sent us
no surprise his receivers and godwin and
evans the favorites at the top with a b
coming in right behind them remember no
grunk in this game so you're looking at
some dark horse tight end candidates and
cameron breit oj howard they got the
two-headed backfield that's really been
one guy this year led by leonard fernett
ronald jones in the doghouse a little
bit and the underdog and tyler johnson
here so
pretty big board we're excited to look
at it today and we're excited to hear
from you greg tell the people what we're
giving away today
ty you'll see how we do things around
here i'm gonna i'm gonna tell you how we
do things we give away hoodies we give
away jerseys
and just cause i'm feeling special just
cause i'm feeling special and just cause
you here bro just cause you here i'm
giving away an iphone 13 today so don't
go anywhere stay locked in y'all stay
locked in stay right here i'm giving
away that iphone 13. uh the jersey's
gonna go to the winning lock legend and
the iphone will go to the commenter and
we'll go to a commenter at the end of
the show so stay around stick around
chill out with me connor ty and uh
potentially win that iphone but what i
need you guys to do right now is get in
the comments and if you want a jersey if
you want a hoodie and if you want this
iphone i need gifts i need emojis and i
need winners only please in the comments
please and just for fun ty just for fun
i'm gonna show y'all how i do it man we
gonna give out a hoodie right now uh ty
connor this right here ty is the handy
dandy ipad and this is how everybody
wins their hoodies this is how everybody
wins their jerseys and this is how
somebody is going to win that iphone so
i'm in the comments right now i am in
the comments and goat garden goat garden
has a
has a gift it says greg sprinkles connor
you know how i feel when they talk to me
yeah you know
talk to me
very often all right speaking of faith
we got we got four legendary picks to
show you uh the last one standing is our
squad ride leader they get the jersey
they get the title but before we get
into that let's take a look at some of
the anytime touchdown videos we got sent
last week that didn't make the show we
have to show you guys so here they are
damn bro who you got to get a touchdown
this weekend anytime td score here it is
for the walk in a week if i win super
shock if i lose tyler lock it
[Music]
i see you landing
[Music]
creativity is looking great so keep more
of those videos coming i might have to
put a safety warning on the next time we
ask for these we're getting a little
nuts all right first pitch of the week
comes from hood rich nathan that's right
you heard it here hood rich nathan tell
us who's catching that record breaker
today
all right
rich nathan going with a b that plus
money that plus 450 looking good and
he's got a pretty good contender here a
familiar face in riley sorbo riley let's
see who you guys see some chickens
coming up
all right you guys know the mission
tom brady he's going to throw
the record pass
to which player today we've got
fournette
with the runaway oh man cameron great
mike evans didn't even have a chance
all of them love those too so we're now
oh my goodness all right you've seen our
first two pitches greg tell the people
what we need right now
what i need everybody to do
is get in the comments and tell me who
we should ride with should we ride with
the obstacle legend and antonio brown or
should we go to the farm
and
ride with the chicken legend and leonard
fournette uh thai
which way are you leaning are you going
a b or are you going leonard fournette
on the farm
you know what
i'm gonna go
leonard fournette on the farm because
tom likes the
uh the dump offs you know he likes the
tight ends and the running back so i and
he's not going to force it you know just
to break the record to try to go
downfield to ab or godwin or someone
like that so you know i i think on that
particular
play when he breaks the record leonard
fournette
drop down screen something like that
yeah i'm rolling with ty i would go with
fournette as well i like the chicken
concept too i'm terrified of chickens
roosters anything like that but i still
like the video
fournette has been the guy right it has
we haven't seen we've seen very little
of ronald jones since that opening
kickoff uh week one fumble so
fournette's gonna be on the field a lot
but doesn't matter what i think greg
what do the people think right now they
get to decide this in the end
connor before i hop into the comments
let me just give my take here uh
a for effort for it for antonio brown
the obstacle legend uh that was good
effort uh but the chicken legend and
riley servo won me over and you guys
make a great point ty talks about how
tom likes to dump the ball down and
leonard fournette's right there so i
mean
i'm rocking with leonard fournette but
let me hop into these comments it's not
about what i think it's not about what
y'all think it's about what the people
are thinking and i'm seeing a lot of a b
i'll be honest i'm seeing a lot of a b
connor i got mad dodger in the comments
talking about a b i got
i got mike ritter mike ritter is in the
comments he's he's shouting out riley
sorbo in the in the in the chicken
legend shout out to you uh both of the
people i just said you're walking away
with a hoodie i got
i got louis marquetta louis macquado
rocking with aba
i'm gonna do it like this connor i'm
gonna do like this ty the next one i'll
land on that's just who's gonna win this
round okay next one i land on that's
just who's gonna win this round and
bam
i got maxil rexel maxwell rexel saying
leonard fournette and the chicken legend
shout out to you maxwell rexella you are
walking away with a hoodie therefore
connor
ty
the chicken legend and leonard fournette
is moving on to the next round chicken
legend that's o'reilly yeah shout out to
riley serbo moving on the chicken legend
leonard fournette but we still have two
challengers remaining on to the next
round pitch comes from another familiar
face that's w trammell let's see who you
got w trammel
to get that record pass
the boat legend going with chris godwin
the favorite on the board right there
but still plus money so it's not a
chalky pick i still like it greg what do
we need from the people right now
what i need you guys to do is get in the
comments and tell us who we should ride
with if we riding with the boat legend
and chris godwin or we're keeping it on
the farm with the chickens man my guy
riley sorbo rocco with leonard fournette
tai
you already know i'm gonna ask you which
way are you leaning did the boat legend
wing you over are you still being loyal
to the farmland and the chickens
i'm still being loyal to the farmland i
mean
the boat it was cool bowl ledge it was
cool but uh i know tom brady and i know
when it comes down to it he's gonna dump
it off to keep the chains going and live
to play another day so odds are
he will go to leonard fournette and i'm
gonna i'm gonna stick with that i don't
give a damn what y'all show
i'm going with linda
you heard ty's rocking with fournette
until the end i'm gonna stay with
fournette here as well because i don't
pick favorites and godwin was the guy at
the top all right greg what do you think
jumping yeah please do
no hey now it feel it ronk was playing
oh there and now he might do that
intentionally yes just so
now it'll be a whole totally different
story if bronck was playing i don't
think he's going to be that much
emphasis even though antonio brown
was here for a cup of coffee you know
what i mean but hey
grump is hands down he would have made
it he would have made it a point to
break that record yeah that's a moment
they want together right exactly exactly
exactly and those guys they do
everything together so it wouldn't shock
them to have that record craig what do
you think of this
uh
i mean the boat legend i i'll just say
this pick folks floats my boat i'll just
leave it at that you guys see what i did
there but
this chris godwin i know he likes to
find him he likes to find him deep likes
to find him down the field maybe it
might may happen in one pass who knows
but
um
it's not about what i think we've been
through this before i'm going to hop
back into this handy-dandy ipad and give
away some more hoodies and then i'm
going to see who the people
thinks is moving on to the next round i
got
i got jt for mvp 0 says godwin he's
rocking with a boat legend shout out to
you jt mvp zero you were walking away
with the hoodie uh i got
mellow for rookie of the year melo ricky
of the year is agreeing with you ty he
says if only if only gronk was there we
all know gronk will be getting this pass
if gronk was playing tonight
gronk odds would probably not even be in
the uh it probably will not even be in
the plus it'd probably be like negative
minus 1 10 round there because we all
know that gronk probably will be
getting that pass if he was in the game
i'll give away one more hoodie and then
we're gonna move on here we go uh
i got j
dje779 says godwin dje7797d
says godwin therefore the boat legend
chris godwin is moving on to the next
round shout out to w trammell shout out
to w trammell yeah second round goes to
w trammell chris godwin the favorite on
the board and now the favorite to win
but we still have one more round all
right somebody's got to take home this
jersey someone's got to take home the
squad rod leader title all right winner
takes all final round whoever wins the
next one gets that boost from draftkings
everybody should go jump on that let's
do it next one up is from jesse
burnstone jesse let's see the pick here
evans
the loch ness monster legend going with
mike evans here so receiver number one
versus receiver number two
man i kind of like where they're going
with this greg what do we need from the
people to decide the title winner for
week number four
what i need you guys to do is hop into
the comments and let us know who's going
to win this let us know who is going to
win are you guys rocking with chris
godwin plus 330 mike evans plus 400 boat
legend loch ness legend
it's getting down to the nitty gritty
and ty you already know what i'm gonna
do i'm calling on you
i'm calling you baton lead off who are
you rocking with you rocking with chris
godwin are you rocking with mike evans
to catch this pass from tom brady
now if i had to choose two or two uh one
of those two receivers
i would say
mike evans because he's the the
downfield guy you know what i mean so
that could be one one ball one ball he
can he can
it can be done so as a matter of fact
you know what he goes to he goes uh god
one more so you know what i'm going to
say i'm going to say god i don't see god
one but if it's one pla pass because he
does so many things down the field and
mike evans he can put an end to all of
it
with one play yeah yeah
how many yards do we need man i'm sorry
68.
this could be in the first quarter
yeah this is definitely going to be in
the first quarter it's going to be in
the first quarter you know what if i'm
just i got i got to go with godwin on
that one because he seems like tom looks
for him a little bit more
it's tough it's a total toss up i'll go
the other way with mike evans he's
coming off a 10 target week that's a
season high for him but you know brady
he he spreads around the ball like no
one else it could be god it could be our
boy lenny fournette back on the farm
even though we're not going with that
here
all right greg what's your final take
people think
uh let me hop into this handy dandy let
me hop into this handy dandy guy hey the
comments are jumping i just want you
guys know the comments are jumping i got
sean powell rocking with the chris
godwin gif i would show you guys but the
comments are just going to keep jumping
uh i got k3 in dawg
rocking with the mike evans gift mike
evans is uh he's bobbing and weaving you
know he's bobbing and weaving in the
gift uh here we go i got boat legend is
a lock shout out to
oh shout out to anthony lindemann
anthony lindemann said boat legend is a
lock hey everybody that i mentioned you
guys are walking away with a hoodie
this next one i read we're just gonna
call it okay ty okay connor here we go
let's do it
bam
mike evans
mike evans i got e m rams em ram says
mike evans for short so they're for ty
therefore connor
we are riding with mike evans uh shout
out to jesse bernstein in the loch ness
legend we're riding with mike evans to
win let me show you something ty i'm
gonna show you some magic
on live right now i'm gonna show you
some magic let's pull up this graphic
let me show y'all what only
we can do here on the squad ride uh you
guys see where it says mike evans plus
400 poof that there's the magic right
there ty there is the magic right here
okay
we we just boosted it we just boosted it
from 400
plus 400 to plus 500
thanks to our friends at draftkings
check
br betting social for a link to the odds
boost send us your screenshots of your
bets send us your videos of your
celebrations we
want winners
only
please and we're not done yet we got
lots to give away you got hoodies to
give away you've got an iphone to give
away you know the deal by now you hang
out in the br betting community app we
ask you
every week something different this week
it's what tom brady prop is a lock let's
take a look at some of the most popular
brady props on the board these are the
ones that you see every single week
passing yard total touchdown total
completions my personal favorite get the
old man's legs moving the brady rushing
touchdown at plus 380. but let's take a
look at the special props with brady
coming back to foxborough the special
props of the game draftkings offering a
25 profit boost on for tonight you can
bet up to three and take advantage of
the boost all kinds of big-time ones
basically his career highs
a number of completed passes for him to
get over that 67 and a half passing yard
mark we asked you in the app for your
favorites and we picked two comments to
look at greg let him know what's up
yes sir i got you connor i need
everybody to get in the comments and
tell us which of these comments you like
better i'm giving a hoodie to whichever
you choose let's take a look at the
first comment from the nerfy legend
himself
troy hermo let's take a look at the
comment there it is
ty my guy says brady's gonna throw a
touchdown pass in each half and he's
calling it a lot easy money what easy
money ty what do you think
i mean it would have been more
interesting if you said a touchdown in
each quarter yes
touchdown
oh man especially to mike evans and
chris godwin i think you'd have a good
chance ty
yeah exactly real real good you know i i
i agree that that's a lock but that is
not that's not too much of a challenge
for
someone
greg what else
my boy ty my boy ty's it says that's a
lot uh but let's move on to the next one
let's move on to the next one
from bald eagle one two four a connor
bald eagle one two four eight says brady
breaks the record on his first drive oh
this is interesting we just talked about
this
we just talked about this tai
what do you think do you think this is a
good tape
i think that's a damn good take and you
know what just to get it out the way
it's going to be so much celebration is
going to be the whole i don't know what
they got planned on down there i'll be
i'll be there i don't know what they got
planned but you know it's going to be
some 15 20 minute you know celebration
of time bretty you know they're going to
stop the game
let's just get it out the way because
you know they're going to stop the game
celebrate do all that so yes the first
uh the first drive you know could be it
and i i like that you know because if
he's going to come out swinging knowing
tom you know and and his coach and bruce
arians they want to make a point right
away let's get this record and let's go
and finish the game play football so i i
agree that he gets it in the first drive
yeah get the distraction out of the way
that's a lot of yards but not a lot of
yards for this offense right so when you
look at it yeah they're going to have
their foot on the gas and just want to
make it right about the football after
this is over so greg what do people
think of these
hey it's so funny i'm i'm looking i'm
looking at the comments as they come in
i got steelers kb he got an eagle flying
the guy named was bald eagle he has a
bald eagle flying he has a gift shout
out to you steelers kb you're walking
away with a hoodie uh i got a
mou 8 12 a mou-812 says bald eagle1248
for the win
so uh
they're loving my my guy bald eagles
take of the first drive brady uh
breaking the record i got one more i got
one more for you connor
um first play he's going to break the
record first play one big play to mike
evans knockout on the sideline
just for the vibes i'm giving them a
hoodie i'm giving the money sal cam
millery south cam millery you are
walking away with a hoodie for your take
and also bald eagle
is walking away with a hoodie for his
take because everybody seems to like tom
brady breaking the record in the first
drive
that's right all right let's look at
some bold bets we've talked all about
all the things brady's gonna do we have
not talked about if the patriots can
stop him and ty
i mean you're a legend hall of fame
corner you played with brady you played
for belichick you've won three super
bowls with them you know these guys as
well as anybody that's played in the nfl
do you think bill knows what it takes i
mean he definitely knows but has what it
takes more importantly
to shut down brady and the bucks offense
tonight
yes i i really believe that he has
something up his sleeve but i still go
back to what uh i've always said it's
about the personnel you know coach
belichick can't go out there and tackle
nobody can't go out there and cover
nobody he can just put the right pieces
and the right guys on the field to make
it happen do they have the right guys in
that locker room i don't know i mean
that's yet to uh be seen now if you and
and if you took bill belichick and the
defense that i played on and with myself
uh william mcginnis teddy brewski all
those guys
oh it was on yeah
we gonna win i i'll tell you if we had
that type of personnel
it would be a totally different uh
conversation you know as far as brady
coming back yeah it seems like we had
that type of defense yeah it seems like
the patriots always have that number one
corner whether it was you obviously
they've had rivas they've had gilmore i
like jc jackson a lot but that's a lot
to ask for one guy against brady so we
want to know is he gonna throw an
interception tonight the current line
for brady to throw an interception
it's the over under a set at
a half basically is he gonna throw one
is he gonna not that's all we wanna know
you've picked the guy off not a lot of
people can say that really there's not a
lot of people that can say that do you
think he'll throw an interception in his
return to foxborough tonight
um
no i don't
you know what damn it yeah
there we go pulls money
yeah because because the defense got to
step up you know what i mean so being a
defensive guy if you go in with the
mentality of he's not gonna i'm not
gonna make a play you know you're not
gonna make one so as a defensive guy i'm
taking this if i'm there damn he gonna
throw an interception you know what i
mean i hope everyone in there feels the
same way that i would feel as as a
defensive back you got to look at that
as a challenge so
uh i know when courtney he'll be ready
back there he he knows tom pretty well
so maybe he can come up with a play uh
like i said uh stefan gilmore
he's not there but jackson
hey you know he's gonna get tried see
that's the thing brady is gonna try you
so can you make can you make it
play
jc jackson you know what i mean he
probably wouldn't try uh um cause he
tried me and paid for it you know what i
mean he might not try stefan gilmore but
brady's gonna try you it's up for you to
come out there and uh make a play yeah
absolutely i know jc jackson was
questionable but if he's on the field
i'm i'm with you all the way greg what
are the comments think so far
uh i was in the comments actually i was
in the comments uh they're going all
over the place i'm just gonna give out
one hoodie though just gonna give out
one honey i say
i see tanaka plan says patriots need tai
law to step in
stop brady from cooking them ty they
want you back out there on the field
tanaka playing wants you back out there
on the field uh shout out to tanika
playing you were walking away with a
hoodie
oh man all right you know the odds of
people that
was out there on the field
he would definitely
score a touchdown because i can't run no
more
i appreciate it no you don't want me out
all right we're almost out of time so
let's get these boldest bets and then
let's thank ty for joining us these are
not locks these are fun long shots we
want to see hit i finally got one last
week mike williams caught his two
touchdowns i'm feeling good greg i know
trey sermon scored you and i are we're
kind of hot right now i'm not going to
lie we're kind of hot all right
boldest bets here
greg let's get into it
let me talk to him connor i got you
everybody get in the comments and tell
me whether you're riding with me
what you guys probably should do or if
you're riding with connor my guy did hit
last week he hit on the the the the two
touchdown yeah go ahead i'll let you
flaunt whatever you did but he did hit
last week connor you hit last week but
what do you got this week for the people
if it's not broken man don't try to fix
it right mike williams wide receiver two
touchdowns let's go a little easier this
week tyree kill two touchdowns this is a
guy that he catches them in bunches and
he's not done that through three weeks
this year against that eagle's secondary
the kansas city chiefs coming off a loss
tyreek hill big time week i think two
touchdowns for him let's roll with it
greg what do you got
i like that i like that i like that
i want to go to i want to go to chicago
i want to go to chicago i got the lions
facing
the bears
and the lions man they they've been
they've been getting hit on their chin
this year ty they went to they they
placed uh san francisco san francisco
you know was beating them and then they
came back and then
they went to play
the packers that game was hard fought in
the first half and then the packers took
care of them in the second half last
week against the ravens it was close
until the end my boy tucker hit the it
was a long field though he's on my
fantasy team 66 yards
yeah they're dues they're due for a win
and they're underdogs they're underdogs
they're due for win i'm gonna go win
margin here i'm gonna go win margin here
connor i think they're gonna win by one
to six points see a close one but i do
see them pulling away with the victory
so uh give me the lions by one to six
points today
ty what are you rolling with you like
tyree kill two touchdowns or the lions
upset over chicago
i
the lions they are due for win
i got to say i i got to say because they
they they fight they fight hard you got
it you got to you got to give it to them
so i like uh i like the alliance with
the upset and then you know justin feels
as much as i like him he's still a you
know young young quarterback and uh and
they're not playing great football they
have a great defense but they're not
playing great football as a team so i
like i like the alliance
upset all right greg i know you still
got this iphone to give away before we
get out of here let's get to it what do
you say
all right let's get straight to it i'm
in the comments man i'm in the comments
and uh
i see big mike 13.
i see big mike 13 says greg i'm riding
with you my men knew that i needed that
new iphone for betting with better
service guess what big mike 13.
christmas has just came early chris has
just came early i hope we're gonna send
you this new iphone and i hope your your
service gets better so you can tap in
with us every week right here
on the squad ride show every sunday but
uh shout out to big mike 13 he is
walking away with the iphone 13. shout
out to big mike that's awesome man good
luck with your wagers everyone congrats
to all our hoodie and jersey winners if
you win br betting's going to reach out
to you in the next 24 hours thanks to
everyone that commented thanks to our
legends hoodrich nathan riley servo w
trammell jesse bernstein thank you to
hall of famer tyler for joining us today
tai do you want to say goodbye to the
people for us
oh yeah hey guys thanks for tuning in we
really uh appreciate it the best have
fun with it don't go too hard
that's right thanks for having me hey
and yo check out that v1 vodkas the new
kid out there on the block uh clean
drinking v1 i got to get you guys some
so give me a call i'm going to send you
a package man but you got double gold
first place official vodka hall of fame
v1 don't drink nothing else nothing else
for this for now
ty i am going to take you up on that
offer i absolutely promise i said i know
greg will too you heard of me one vodka
alongside greg alongside tai my name is
connor rogers see you same time same
place next week enjoy your sunday all
right appreciate it guys
[Music]
you